look at it  this is an enormously significant  jailbreak what we know is that the six  men weren't present at a four o'clock am  head count by prison officers that was  when something was  obviously a miss as far as the israeli  security service were concerned and they  discovered the opening of this tunnel  apparently down into the drainage system  under the prison from the the cell  and that they had been  digging this tunnel apparently for some  months and overnight was the night that  they decided to coordinate their escape  and according to some of these reports  there was coordination suspicion of a  smuggled cell phone  of an escaped car waiting for them so an  intelligence lapse as well as a security  lapse  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  foreign  [Music]